[Applause]
such a good show tonight but first
before ya before we get on with the show
I have to mention something a little
while ago yeah I shot a remote where I
got to know an associate producer on the
show named Jordan shlonsky one of our
there he is right there one of our staff
member is he's a hypnotist in his spare
time and anyway then a little later on
we showed that remote people seem to
really love it so then a little later on
Jordan fancies himself a food and wine
expert and he decided to take me to his
favorite Italian restaurant do way in
Manhattan so we did that and we brought
a camera crew and I showed a tape of my
dinner with Jordan on the show and the
response was phenomenal we seemed to
have some kind of chemistry that people
respond to so anyway we noticed there
was a lot more footage from my dinner
with Jordan slansky that we hadn't shown
we thought people deserve to see it so
here it is ladies and gentlemen part two
of my dinner with Jordan slansky I want
to share it with you right now
enjoy tonight we're gonna be eating
foods from the earth of the earth by the
earth and for the earth well typically
as is the Italian Way you want food
that's traveled the least distance from
the earth to your plate okay
everything is local if you're in
Piemonte a in it illegal drink of wine
from Piemonte a so what you're saying is
we're on Third Avenue
we should eat pork that was captured and
killed on Third Avenue you want to be
careful not to overfill your wine glass
for maximum impact you need to let the
wine aerate more than that fill will
allow please don't would you say please
don't it's the most emotion I've ever
seen you show please not what happened
there what did you see me doing to
bothered you I prefer if you didn't pour
your wine back into the bottle why well
it will only end poorly
oh yes yes a Pepe he's called a pet
Penmark Debenham it's a brown Julio's
from Mexico please he says pimienta
fresca
oh I'm sorry stop we were an Italian
restaurant wet on wait what's going on
why are you letting him do it himself I
prefer to do it myself you like your
hands on a nice long shaft is that the
idea no wait which a fun a little bit
see that comes out every person projects
an aura a color every person has a color
my color is red
I'm not talking about the clothes I wear
I'm talking about the invisible aura
around me where did you hear this what
happened to you I didn't hear it
anywhere you didn't hear it how do you
know your color is red that's what I
feel I feel that my color is a red I
have a red personality ryaba red Vespa
I'm dry red wine red is in general my
favorite color
do you know what my color is red
you're coming on to me no you just said
like all red red red I love red and I
said what car my anyone you're a red
then you looked at me for a long time
you've never had water until you've been
to Iceland what are you talking about
the purity of the water and you can
bring I you could buy Iceland spring
water in the US but to drink
Icelandic water in Iceland is heaven if
you're saying stuff now just to say it
what do you mean the water in Iceland is
heaven what does that even mean it's
just water water is odorless and
tasteless its purest form that's true
however there are minerals and water all
these things learn taste they'll end
consistency the hardness or softness is
it true that you Vulcans have reversed
organs that your hearts on this side of
your body and your livers over here is
that true the human heart is on the side
these are some of my various travels
around the world I want you to
understand the beauty of this quality of
light to sit in this lava field under
this beautiful Sun penetrating my being
it's something that I can only hope to
impart so I'm sure your being has been
penetrated potent chela oh god oh god
the vines of Sangiovese from where this
wine came yeah eating just feet from the
vines the ultimate poetry the ultimate
beauty in life I promise you this I will
not kill you myself
but I will have you killed
I'll have you wiped out I am subject to
the same winds the Sun the air that
created the wine that I'm drinking
there'll be nothing that links meteor
murder there will be no physical link
between your dead body and myself but
you will be murdered I will order it but
I'll have no you know blameless in the
eyes of the international courts that I
proxy kill you go how soft your fields
so green all right whisper tales of gore
okay now you're just being an ass what
are you doing of how we calmed the tides
of war Oh God we are your overlords this
rush the Vikings it's just a rush song
his Led Zeppelin immigrant song written
about this beautiful country of Iceland
they come from the land of the ice and
snow from the Midnight Sun where the hot
springs blow do you know this one you
need a woman you need what you my love
what a Tanner yes my dog
[Applause]
[Music]
you know that one you want me to go with
you don't you know you just said I have
to use the restroom and you look at me
for a really long time
I'll call it's a diuretic do you want me
to go to the bathroom with you no okay
it seems sort of like you did feel Susan
I'm not going with you I understand you
thinks I'm going with him I'm not gonna
go with imagine me
[Music]
[Applause]
I swear to god he's a real person here
in Jordan's landscape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you walk out like the Pope or Mussolini
and two people who the hell do you think
people are you completely blow my mind
all right we're gonna take a little
break he's a real person we'll take a
break when we come back
Seann William Scott's here stick around